the roads leading south are empty of
cars fighting's intensifying here as
ukraine tries to recapture the city of
kerason
we traveled with a military escort
through checkpoints
along desolate highways to reach the
slowly shifting front lines
the villages have all been heavily
shelled
and it is getting worse
there is now fierce fighting along the
southern front
over the last hour we've heard the sound
of incoming fire it's been pretty
constant over there that's a ukrainian
position
you can see the smoke on the horizon
just above the tree line
but the villagers here are pretty much
deserted
almost everyone has left
and nowhere is safe
the attacks come night and day and those
that remain say they don't have the
resources to leave
this is where you go
lubov shows me where she waits out the
barrages of russian artillery
it is a dark and lonely existence
is
after six months of conflict the junk of
war along the southern front litters the
countryside
the front lines haven't moved
significantly here for months
this russian armor was destroyed at the
beginning of the invasion
along with many of putin's soldiers
and ukraine is hoping its forces will be
able to roll back the kremlin's war
machine from areas further south
as it launches a counter-offensive
but the units stationed here say they
need more supplies from the west
to win this war we
we need
more weapons heavy weapons including
artillery and ammunition
along the line of contact trenches
stretch for miles
it's quite quiet here at the moment but
at night
the shelling
and the missiles start landing on this
position
the russians
just over there were obscured by this
tree line
there is a worry amongst the soldiers
western support may fade without steady
progress
but a defeat here they warn will have
consequences for democracies everywhere
the troops are a hundred percent
confident they can win but ukraine says
there are signs moscow is becoming more
desperate
attacks on civilian targets are
increasing
in mikalayev residents live under the
constant threat of bombing
at this bus stop seven were killed by a
russian rocket
and this hotel nearby was struck by a
missile
they want ukrainians to be frightened
because they want to
push us and
to take our freedom
the war here is entering a new phase but
this conflict will not be over quickly
the artillery slugging match for the
south will be a slow and deadly grind
alex rossi sky news on the southern
front